i built this beautiful website deployed  it then my client mysteriously vanished  without paying the bill i tried calling  the police but they didn't know what a  javascript was luckily i'm a developer  with a very particular set of skills  skills i've acquired over a very long  career  skills that make me a nightmare for  people like you before i deployed i  wrote a javascript poison pill a script  that checks my api for the payment  status and each day it's past two it  subtracts .01 from the opacity on the  body tag at first you barely notice but  each day the website fades out just a  little bit by 100 days it's gone  completely and the content is replaced  with a friendly gaming reminder